good morning hick it's tuesday greetings
from kovid uh great video last week
here's the literal opposite of it do you
know anything about me it's that i am
america's leading uh kovid stricken cars
versus influencer slash analyst this car
oh no see that would be a massive issue
for me because one of my biggest fears
is getting unexpectedly drenched in raw
sewage and that looked like it maybe had
sewage in the back of it
there we have a uh
what i think is is known in the cars
versus world as a as a proper issue now
there is the smartest car in the squid
[Laughter]
i think i was going for a squad
but i like squid better sometimes you
write a line like the most famous
example in my own life is
fell asleep the way you
fall in love fell in love the way you
fall asleep slowly than all at once and
you're when i wrote that line i remember
being like
that's pretty good and it is i still i
still like it okay but it's not nearly
as good as the
smartest car in the squid that's
it's proper genius you know i think i
would drive around the giant bulge i
don't understand the urge to conquer the
giant culture it feels like toxic
masculinity to me but i would
i would survive that i would be very
freaked out afterwards
um i would probably call my therapist
and be like you'll never guess what was
in the road it was a giant bulge this
one
i don't like no that's a no this is a
big problem for me because i do not
enjoy a spinny ride i don't like the
teacups at disney world and i do not
like my car flipping over in multiple
directions like dozens of times and then
landing on it but you know what it's
like i always say if it rides i lie live
live i'm working on pun okay um i got a
little foggy brain
this one
again
i think that's
i think that's gonna be a real issue for
me
i think i think i've got myself a
i think i've got myself a proper problem
although
if it rides our lives i wonder what i
would have to like be faced with in
order to indulge in a real-life version
of cars versus giant ramp this is of
course um not gonna be the kind of thing
that
one emerges from
uh like i guess if like
somebody was like hey you gotta do cars
versus giant ramp or we're gonna
exterminate the human race i would be
like oh finally it's my deep impact
moment it's my chance to
you know be the hero that second grade
me wanted to be
but
the problem is that it told me is pretty
cowardly
so i might try to get like
somebody to volunteer as tribute for
being realistic
i might be like don't don't we need
don't we need young adult novelists in
the
glorious dystopian future that awaits us
on the other side of this great
sacrifice i love the idea of going to a
cocktail party and like meeting somebody
and saying like hey what do you uh
what do you do for a job and they'll be
like oh i i make tick tocks
uh simulating trains versus giant pit
outcomes and i'd be like oh that's
that's cool of you have you learned
anything
and they'd be like yeah the big thing
i've learned in my research so far is
that it's actually it's actually pretty
bad
for trains to run into giant tits i got
rainbow colored train i wonder if
changing the color changes the outcome
i'm gonna take a wild guess and say that
it might still be an issue for there to
be a giant bit
and it is
[Laughter]
this is the most fun i've had in like
at least three days